consider the formula p is equal to w
divided by t where p represents power
w represents the represents work and has
units of joules and joules can be
expressed as kilograms times meter
squared per second squared and t
represents time and has units of seconds
and when you get to physics class you'll
get very familiar with things like
joules which can be represented as
kilogram times meter squared per second
squared and things like power but here
we're going to learn to manipulate these
units so that they they make sense so it
says select an appropriate measurement
unit for power and what we've seen
multiple times in our mathematical
careers is that on a certain level you
can manipulate units in a lot of the
same ways that you would manipulate
variables or numbers so if power is
equal to work divided by time we could
also say that the units for power
are going to be the units for work
divided by the units for time so the
units for work
the units for
work
right over here is joules
and so we could write it's going to be
joules
per and then the unit for time is
seconds
so you might want to say it's joules per
second
but we don't see
joules per second as a choice here so we
probably want to expand out joules as
being kilogram meters squared per second
squared so let's do that so this is
going to be equal to joules we can
rewrite as
kilogram
times
meter squared
over
second squared and we're going to divide
all of that by seconds
all of that by
seconds and so what's that going to be
well we could rewrite this this is going
to be
kilograms
and i'm intentionally not trying not to
skip any steps kilograms
times meters squared
per second squared and dividing by
seconds is the same thing as multiplying
by 1 over seconds so times
1 over seconds and so if we treat these
units the way that we might treat things
like variables this would be equal to in
the numerator
we would have kilogram
times
meter squared or kilograms times square
meters over in the denominator of second
squared times seconds you have seconds
to the third power
so a unit for power one way to express
the units for power could be kilogram
meter squared per second cubed and we
see that this is this first choice
kilograms meters squared per second
cubed